I want to add a new attribute to our form, and this one is going to be called "method."
I go up here.
Let's add method and make it equal post.
Now, the default method has been get.
We've talked about this in Unit 1, the difference between a couple methods,
so we mentioned that a couple methods exist,
and the most important ones are going to be using our get and post.
If you don't specify method at all, it defaults to get, and that's what we've been seeing.
We've been doing get requests, and the parameters in the URL
are called get parameters.
Now we're going to use a new method called "post,"
so make this change, and let's go to our browser.
Okay, here we are at our familiar form again.
Let's type in some text and hit submit.
When you clicked submit, what happened?
Was the text that we entered displayed?
An error message was displayed?
The request headers were displayed, or we ran a Google search with our text request?